this was a pretty tricky sequence to
film even before you get fire involved
Chris Hemsworth had to rehearse this
fight sequence for extraction 2 for
roughly four or five weeks before
filming because every movie needed to be
incredibly precise in order to get the
shot right and Not only was Chris
fighting against 300 to 400 extras in
the freezing Prague winter his jacket
had also been lit on fire because
according to director Sam Hargrave the
mental image was something that I
couldn't pass up I had to cover my arm
in flammable liquid set it on fire and I
had to go through
and of course he handled it with all the
grace of an Asgardian Prince it was a
call not so I appreciated them off if
Chris keeps these crazy stunts up we're
sure to have another Tom Cruise on our
hands here